y nos preguntan cuál expresión podemos
usar para encontrar el número que falta
en el patrón pausa en el vídeo y traten
de resolverlo por su cuenta antes de que
lo resolvamos juntos vamos a resolverlo
juntos la forma en que yo lo haría es
primero tratar de encontrar el patrón
que hay entre estos números para después
tratar de encontrar el que falta para
pasar de 36 a 45 parece que tuvimos que
agregar 9 así que sumó 9 y para pasar de
63 a 72 sumamos 9 y es bueno asegurarnos
de que el patrón que creemos ocurre se
aplique a todos los números que podemos
ver para pasar de 72 a 81 también
sumamos 9 así que estoy bastante segura
de que para pasar de este 45 al espacio
en blanco sumó 9 al 45 y en las opciones
vemos que efectivamente en la opción b
está a 45 + 9 ni siquiera tenemos que
calcular el número que falta aquí aunque
algunos de ustedes ya saben que de 54
solo sabemos que este 45 le sumamos 9 y
el resultado irá en el espacio en blanco
otro ejemplo esto es un poco diferente
dice si el patrón continúa cuál será el
sexto número en el patrón pausa en el
vídeo y traten de resolverlo muy bien
primero encontremos el patrón para pasar
de 2 a 6 parece que sumamos cuatro luego
sumamos cuatro de nuevo para pasar de
seis a diez y volvemos a sumar cuatro
para pasar de 10 a 14 así que parece que
sumamos 4 cada vez estos son los
primeros 1 2 3 4 números en el patrón el
quinto número en el patrón es 14 + 4 o
sea 18 y el sexto número en el patrón es
18 + 4 que es igual a 22 este es el
número que nos piden el sexto número en
el patrón así que elegimos la opción de
hagamos otro ejemplo aquí nos dicen la
siguiente tabla muestra el número de
vueltas que carlos corrió alrededor de
la pista cada día cuál regla describe el
patrón mostrado por el número de vueltas
que hizo carlos como siempre pausa en el
vídeo y traten de resolverlo por su
cuenta
muy bien parece que cada vez que pasa un
día el número de vueltas incrementa en
tres por lo que si queremos saber el
número d
del día siguiente que es el sexto día
sumamos tres al número de vueltas del
día 5
aquí el patrón es que suma 3